the Jews are at it again by the way it
smells like farts in here dude for us
this guy before the video starts he goes
I'm Gonna Go Far outside I did and right
when you left I look at Steve when I go
five bucks this he brings it back in I
said you trailed it he was outside for
like five seconds dude I farted and I
even dusted my pants off and then I came
in oh you dusted your pants yeah I smell
like mervins
dude you could smell it guy goes right
outside the door keeps his butt against
the crocodile do us a favor fart to the
catalytic converter turn the car engine
on and then fart in the tail air filter
now take that outside far into the air
filter air filter just dies although
thank you for farting outside at least
trying to yeah thank you
because old Bart you just let them rip